[Music]
this is a medical emergency and every
day it's getting worse here
critically ill children are squeezed
into cots two or three at a time
there's just not enough room and there
are too many patients in desperate need
and every day more are coming
this is the top children's hospital in
afghanistan it's the best there is but
they're running out of everything
medicine supplies equipment everything
[Music]
medical staff know they just can't treat
their patients but they keep trying
anyway they've all very poorly these
little ones
seriously
this one is
[Music]
and it's difficult but are their chances
of survival quite low
cp treatments no treatment
afghanistan
[Music]
there's over 500 patients in the indira
gandhi hospital they've only room for
300. ward after ward is exactly the same
jam-packed with really poorly babies and
children
the head doctor says they're overwhelmed
by demand and lack of equipment is
necrotizing into politics foreign aid
lost after the taliban takeover is
critical he says if they are to save
lives
there's a need for
some good drugs yes you don't purchase
from
outside the hospital this is a big
problem our peoples like these are very
poor we have need some like we need for
ventilator machine we don't have
ventilator there's a need for a
ventilator we don't have cpu machine
ventilator machine you know for icu this
is a very need for ico
[Music]
aziz struggles to pick up his daughter
moslema and place her next to her
brother
they've come from two provinces to get
here they've genetic kidney disease like
two of their siblings already dead their
chances of survival are slim
the chance of
survivors
too low
i mean
80 percent chance of
dying
and that's because there's nothing you
can do we can nothing no because we
don't have any facility for these
patients here
right yeah
and again
this is probably the best children's
hospital in the entire country right an
entire yeah governmental country a
governmental hospital yeah but uh public
uh i mean we have
private ones here private 80 of the
population too expensive too expensive
they can afford it
and is that what you'll find you just
don't have the resources
for the poor patients we don't have any
good results for the patients
because
from one side we we have got more
patients i mean load of patients are too
high from every side of afghanistan can
the patients here
and
the facilities too
low
this must be very hard for you oh it
must be hard for you
yeah
so unfortunately we can do nothing for
these patients for these kind of
patients
as a doctor every day you're coming to
work knowing there's nothing you can do
for these patients unfortunately now
and i must be terrible
so you don't have to get out of the way
many have serious illnesses that could
be successfully treated it's not a lack
of skill here it's a lack of resources
twelve-year-old amina has meningitis
they're struggling to save
health care in afghanistan particularly
in the provinces has been poured for
decades that isn't the issue here the
point is we're in the best children's
hospital in the whole of the country and
they're overwhelmed they just don't have
the resources they don't have the money
they don't have medicines and
many of the children who come here are
simply going to die not because they
couldn't be treated but because there is
no way of treating them they need
international community help the taliban
are in charge here indeed an armed guard
was assigned to us the whole time it's
one of the problems for the
international community
despite the taliban's intransigent
position on many issues the hospital's
president himself a surgeon is asking
for help with this medical crisis
um
a woman grabbed us
she wanted help to buy baby food
can you not get formula anywhere
so really
this little one wasn't actually wrong
because it's starving hungry
and uh there's no formula and that we're
hearing all the i mean even the hospital
doesn't have a formula
it's really
malnutrition across afghanistan is out
of control
the worst effect did come here if they
can make it
sofia is seven she's just arrived
but for the first time in weeks the
family has some hope are you hopeful
that she will get better
for many others though there is nothing
but despair
malnutrition has engulfed two-year-old
shireen khan's body he's fighting for
his life
his mom can do nothing
this is a nationwide medical emergency
goldbasher doesn't care who's to blame
she just wants her son to live
stuart ramsey sky news kabul
i